Speaker 1: Let's start with some very important
actually good news today, at least sort of
if the problem gets fixed.
A judge has ruled that Ron Desantis's new
redistricting map in the state of Florida
is completely unconstitutional.
Not okay.
The lines are going to have to be redrawn.
And this is very good news because what was
done in Florida was such a brazen attempt
to gerrymander to the benefit of Republicans.
And everybody tries to do it whenever they
get the opportunity, they try to do it, there's
no doubt.
But this was so obvious and so brazen that
we were.
If this wasn't stopped by a judge, then all
bets are off.
So we have a very good report from Axios.
Florida judge says the Santos redistrict redistricting
map unconstitutional.
A Florida judge on Wednesday struck down a
portion of a redistricting map drawn by Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis and his staff.
A Leon County Circuit judge, Lane Smith, said.
I am finding that the enacted map is unconstitutional
under the Fair District Amendment because
it diminishes African-Americans ability to
elect the representatives of their choice.
A formal order is expected today or tomorrow
to ensure the maps aren't used in November.
This is a key part, which is not only was
this map found to be unconstitutional, it
can't be allowed to be used in November while
a new map is figured out.
That's an absolutely critical element to this.
DeSantis plan dismantles the north Florida
seat now held by a black Democrat.
The new maps DeSantis called race neutral
make it harder for North Florida voters to
elect a black member of Congress in the fifth
Congressional District, where nearly half
its residents are black.
So the technique that's used here is if you
have, for example, in this case, a district
where you have a black Democrat and nearly
half the residents are black, and you say,
well, this is this is a seat that, as currently
drawn, is likely to be won again by this elected
official.
What you do is you split that district up
and you put some of the black folks in one
Republican district and some of the black
folks in another, so that in neither district
do they have a critical mass.
And in this way, you can take one or two seats.
And in fact, when we look at the map, the
whole point of the map as drawn is to create
a whole bunch a whole bunch of easy Republican
districts while making it very difficult for
Democrats to win.
And of course, if you're looking at this map,
you will see that in southeastern Florida,
the Miami, etc. area, you have a number of
of blue districts.
But these are maps that make it very difficult
for Democrats to win anywhere else.
And part of the way that this is done is by
using general demographic trends.
Black folks tend to vote more for Democrats
than Republicans in Florida.
And you can you can use that to your advantage.
A Democratic aligned redistricting group joined
voting rights and civil rights organizations
to file suit against this map the same day
it was signed into law late last month.
And fortunately, because this doesn't always
happen, it was adjudicated or evaluated relatively
quickly by the judge.
So, listen, nobody's surprised, right?
I mean, this is this is not only the expected
outcome of Ron DeSantis deciding he was going
to redistrict and draw the maps himself.
This is this is a feature, not a bug of what
they do here.
And the most important things here are, number
one, that the judge ruled on this quickly.
But number two, that the judge is expected
today or tomorrow.
Maybe by the time you see this clip, it will
already have been done, not allow these maps
to be used in November.
And one of the other aspects of this is there
is a sort of I don't want to necessarily call
it virtue signaling, but it's a sort of virtue
signaling where many things that Ron DeSantis
has done have not been designed to stand up
to legal scrutiny.
In fact, they were probably done knowing they
wouldn't stand up to legal scrutiny.
The point here is to attempt a whole bunch
of stuff to then be able to use it either
in his reelection campaign, which is getting
going now.
DeSantis is up for reelection in November
as governor of Florida, or it's theorized,
and the polling suggests that he may have
a shot.
It's theorized that Ron DeSantis may try to
run for president, starting with Republican
nominee in 2024.
And so, you know, opening Florida early to
large sporting events when everything else
was shut down, as we were trying to figure
out in 2020, what is COVID, how does it work,
how contagious is it?
All of these things he can use that the don't
say gay bill, the event to commemorate the
victims of communism, I think it was called,
which we talked about earlier this week, obviously
unconstitutional congressional maps.
A lot of this stuff isn't designed to stand
up.
The legal scrutiny because it's not going
to.
But it is designed to allow Ron DeSantis to
take credit for it at some point later.
And it wouldn't be.
I would be shocked if he didn't do it either
for his gubernatorial reelection campaign
or if he does decide to run for president
in in 2024.
Now, just as an update, we've been very, very
closely following.
What are the what are the betting odds when
it comes to the 2024 Republican nominee?
And I actually am trying to find it.
I don't have it in front of me.
Where was this?
Ah, here it is.
Ron DeSantis continues continues to close
in on Donald Trump.
And if we look now at last check, Ron DeSantis
was roughly at $0.31.
Now it's $0.32.
So the whole point here is you now have to
wager $0.32 to win a dollar on Ron DeSantis
being the nominee, meaning that the higher
that number goes, the more likely it is that
DeSantis will be the nominee.
This is the closest it has been between Trump
and DeSantis for as long as we've been tracking
these numbers.
And at one point, DeSantis was down at like
11 or 12 and now up to 32.
He has almost caught up to Donald Trump in
terms of the betting odds.
We could also look at actual polling.
It's just not super accurate this far out
necessarily.
And sometimes looking at betting betting odds
gives you a little more information.
So that's the latest with the Santos and we're
going to continue to follow it.